foreign
let's go to Thai in Baton Rouge
Louisiana what's up Ty
hey hey Dr Jay how are you today I'm
good man how are you dude
we're doing all right doing all right
awesome so what's up
so I'm sure we can go in a couple
different directions but I'll just start
my question and see where it goes okay
so how how can my wife and I come
together on the same page about
parenting decisions whenever we have
polar opposite upbringings
um in terms of well let me say good I
care less just off just on the face I
care less about where you've been and
more about unification about where
you're going
sure so tell me about
tell me about your past that make you
concerned that you can't get together
and go forward in the same direction
one thing I mean the example I want to
bring up is actually in relation to like
a recent event with our our son in his
sleeping habits okay
um a little before that so I grew up in
a household where I think was pretty
decent my parents were always present
they were always available and uh raised
us to be a very good independent adults
my wife again has the opposite to where
she grew up in a pretty volatile home
where one parent was probably
emotionally and verbally abusive and the
other was kind of a peacekeeper
um so she has some Trauma from her past
that I think
gives her some experiences and
perspectives that very different from
mine
um
so that kind of manifests itself today
in that we have a two-year-old son we've
been together for about four years we
have a two-year-old son
and our opinion of his sleeping habits
are polar opposite in terms of
uh I don't think he has a healthy
relationship with sleep and she thinks
that the way that he sleeps or the way
that he doesn't sleep
um is actually somewhat normal and we've
been struggling with this for a while
okay let's get to The Sleep issue but
first I want to say this pretty clearly
your
your childhood may have been free of
trauma or have much less trauma than
your wife's did
your
the resulting wisdom yours is not
Superior to hers
sure yep okay and she learned some
extraordinary lessons about connectivity
and love and hiding and fear and sleep
and things that you didn't learn because
your body didn't have to go to war every
day
and so there is a like just the way
listening to you talk about it your
childhood was Superior to hers and now
we've ended up in this issue and I can't
figure out why she can't see the way I
was raised was the right way and so why
can't we just do it like this
and so I want to be careful of that
train of thought okay because that gets
into mine is better and when mine is
better and you're talking to somebody
who's been through trauma
hers is yeah but I gotta survive and
then now you're talking about the war
you've been having for a couple of years
okay so let's think of Yes Man your
parents must do it they did an awesome
job great and her parents did a
miserable job true those are codes can
both be facts
yet both of your wisdom that you've both
accumulated from you have a great
picture of what it looks like she has an
incredible picture of what survival
looks like that combination can make for
great parents when both of those wisdoms
are honored if one is is given
preferential treatment over the other
man you're talking about that's a recipe
for a mess so
um the the conversation about the sleep
we can get to it it's going to be less
of this particular issue and more of a
framework that you and your wife can
develop for how do we
how do we uh make decisions when we I
want it one way and he wants it the
other way or vice versa right so tell me
about the sleep thing
so our son is about two years old okay
um he has since birth
um never I think been able to sleep
through the night I can count probably
on one hand probably that's happened
over the two years okay
um so we have a pretty good bedtime
routine where you know we have dinner
and then good bath time and then we
relax and unease into the the night and
he goes to sleep pretty well but
um he will not fall asleep on his own
and he will only fall asleep if he's on
one of us say rocking or nursing Etc
okay and then typically the the routine
is he'll wake up within a couple hours
after going down and then
he has again has to be rocked back to
sleep
oftentimes I'll start but he gets upset
with me because he wants to nurse and
then
over the night between 11 and up to 5
a.m he's waking up every hour and a half
or so and we'll only go back to sleep if
he's nursing or on one of us and so it's
it's been a challenge
um
so yeah
um and so do you want to just let him
scream and cry it out until he figures
it out or and she doesn't want that
well I think that's what's hard is like
we we do have some good conversations
we'll get into like the approach that
we'd like to use or the approach that we
think might be appropriate
um but again I think like those
backgrounds and thank you for affirming
that because I will say that's one thing
that she's been phenomenal at is she is
very good at communicating her needs and
her experiences and and she's been uh
with a counselor for quite some time and
she I will offer she's been extremely
Brave and amazing and facing her her
past and working through those things
that's awesome and I'm trying to be
supportive of her for all that
um
so
here's the challenge with
um babies and I'm gonna dude you know
this as well as I do when this comes out
do not look at the YouTube comments
because there's going to be a billion of
them okay yeah everyone's got an opinion
on sleep hygiene and sleep this and the
kids need to be whatever
my first impulse right wrong or
indifferent well here's my very very
first impulse is I'm not a pediatrician
and I'm not a children's sleep expert
okay and so finding a doctor that you
trust in your community that could give
you some
some what I would say some informed
guidance does he know y'all you and your
wife does he know your baby and the
particular uh you know
family history and blood
um you know uh details and dietary
habits can can he give you some or she
give you some informed guidance there
okay so that's important
beneath that is I like to trust a baby
yeah and if a baby is telling you I'm
not safe
something in my environment is telling
me I'm not okay
my first impulse is to ask me and my
wife what tension are we putting out
into the world in here that we've
created that this is an unsafe
environment for this kid to go to sleep
in
that may be an unfair and I don't say it
to blame it I just want I'm the adult
and I want to go look in the mirror
first before I start blaming a
two-year-old for not doing things the
quote unquote right way does that make
sense
it does so I'm just creating a framework
is there attention and am I sleeping
through the night does my wife sleep
through the night right does I took I
took it off right before just my do I
track my sleep with like a whoop strap
and find out am I sleeping at night at
night or is my baby doing exactly what
I'm doing I've just learned some tricks
to cover it up in the middle of the
night or I don't fully wake up you see
what I'm saying
um so I want to look at me and my wife
do we have anxiety in our home have we
created an anxious life and that this
baby is just mirroring
uh the the environment we've created for
it so if I ask you that does your wife
struggle from anxiety do you have an
anxious home are y'all struggling with
debt or connectivity issues or you and
your wife having a challenging marriage
season right now like what's going on in
your world
we do struggle with some debt we're
babysit too pretty deep
um but frankly I think we we're in a
good place like even though there are
some struggles and things we're working
through we we have a pretty good a way
to communicate and voice our needs and
and stay connected in that way uh and I
will say she she has recently taken a
couple steps to put in boundaries in
place with her parents and you know
based on some steps that she's taking
um I know before we had him
um I mean she had some anxiety at that
would manifest at night and had trouble
sleeping uh this is another I'll just go
ahead and own it um I've always had a
really good relationship with sleep and
so this is actually for me personally
it's been difficult because it's a way
that I feel like I can't connect with my
son um
and so
um
sure so uh I was the kid where I would
go to sleepovers as a kid and I would
actually go to sleep a decent hour
instead of playing up staying up all
night playing video games
um
so I've always just had like a really
healthy relationships sleep and and
decent health habits Etc and so when I
see my son struggling with that at night
and I go to rock him and he he just
won't fall asleep like he'll just stay
awake for an hour or two hours just for
no what I think is no reason but
so it's hard for me to connect with him
that way because I'm I'm trying to
encourage him or teach him and and I
just don't feel that I connect with him
in that way so let me tell you this man
he's two
yeah and you want to impart these wisdom
lessons and you want to give him the
best path forward he's just two he is a
bundle of nerves
that's what he is man he's a bundle of
responses he's slowly coming into his
own right so he's gonna get three and
four and five and you can check out
Piaget I mean you can find the the
stages of development right and he's
going to start transitioning here in the
next year or so and you're going to get
you're going to have a radically
different human a human with a
personality and he's got a personality
now but when he starts chit chatting
with you and talking and being silly or
being very serious you're going to watch
that emerge
what I would tell you if I could go back
man and just I'm saying this with all my
heart
is my son right now he's about he's
gonna be 13 in a few months
dude I
I over informed the first four years of
his life
and I under experienced it with him
I tried to give him a bunch of info and
make him do things the right way
instead of just honoring man he happens
to be a kid who he was the opposite of
your kid my son can go to sleep in the
middle of a of a train wreck
he's like all right good night and he's
out and dude I've struggled with sleep
my whole life and so there was times I
wanted to hang out and play and he just
was going to sleep he needed more sleep
than I needed
um and I thought I wasn't connecting him
that way and he needs to learn how to
toughen up and stay away dude I was I it
wasn't him that was the Divine the the
the connection issue it was me
and so what I would tell you is making
peace with you are in a season say it's
the next six months say it's the next 12
months you are in a season Ty I'm gonna
get less sleep
and so I'm gonna have to be a little
more intentional about my discipline in
the morning when it comes to exercising
it to be a little more intentional about
not snapping at people because I'm going
to be sleep deprived because I got a
little kid in the house
and I'm gonna take advantage of those
couple hours when I quote unquote think
he should be asleep and he needs sleep
and it's best for him man a baby's body
knows
you know what I mean and make peace with
that because what he's going to do is
he's going to feel the tension from Dad
that something's not right and he's
gonna already internalize as a
two-year-old it's his fault he has to
solve this thing
and you don't want a two-year-old
carrying that kind of Burden you don't
want a five-year-old a 10 year old a 20
year old carrying that kind of bird
does that make sense
well it does and I can see that because
I know it has been manifesting for me in
other ways so like I've had issues at
work and performance and
um even when I am working from home I
say just I mean back to your other
question about tension in the house
um me working from home was very
difficult because I always feel like I'm
running behind her late because I'm just
I'm not at my best that's and here's
here's the thing is this your first kid
it is yeah this is this is all of us
parents with our first kid
and listen I got a hard book deadline
after the last couple of days I was I've
been writing for early early and writing
home I just booked a hotel for the next
four days I'm leaving my house because I
can't do it and I feel guilty that I'm
leaving my kids and I feel guilty of
leaving my wife
can't do it and I can sit at home and
just be radioactive and not get any work
done or I just had to be a grown-up and
make other arrangements and it's gonna
cost money it's gonna cost all kind of
it just is it just is and so
I
there's a great lesson having a child
can teach us is how little control we
actually have over the world
yeah and the the quicker you come to
terms with how little power you have
the more peaceful your home will be
because right now you're fighting nature
you're fighting biology you're fighting
a two-year-old
and you you will lose that fight
and even if you win you lose
you see what I'm saying and so here's
what I would love and man I know you're
gonna dude you are gonna get blown up on
the internet on this I am too
about all different kind of sleep
training programs and blah fine yep
whatever
all at the end of all of the programs
and then of all of the blog
I want to make peace with the kid in
front of me
and man I don't have I don't know many
kids that are more disciplined than my
kids they're very disciplined my kids
are they're great they follow the rules
are good kids and they're also
freakishly creative and silly and goofy
and fun because they're children and
it's me making peace with I my job is to
control every little thing make sure
they're on the right
my job is to make sure they don't kill
themselves make sure they're people of
value and integrity which means I gotta
live my life because they're watching me
and it means I've got to honor hey this
one wants to do gymnastics this one's
finding his place or her place in
theater and I thought they were going to
be a wrestler and I'm gonna go with them
in their Journey not force it does that
make sense and that's as little as as
you know what I'm gonna try for 30 days
just to make peace with the sleep thing
he'll go to sleep when he goes to sleep
and we're gonna honor that in the house
what we're going to do is instead of
focusing on managing his sleep schedule
we're going to focus on removing the
tension from the house
now dude I might be out to lunch it
worked in my home it might not work in
everybody's home but I would challenge
you to try that as you feel yourself
getting frustrated don't judge yourself
just be curious about like oh dude I'm
starting to get pissed again and he's
two I'm not gonna let him make me mad
because he's two
he's just not tired so we're getting the
trucks out
and we're gonna play trucks and I'm
gonna get two hours less sleep tonight
and I'm gonna have to really be
intentional tomorrow because I could be
it I could be not cool when I'm when I'm
sleepy
and we have a toddler we have a
two-year-old life just gets sideways and
so me and my wife are gonna have to
learn how to be married now with a
two-year-old
and I don't I I don't want to speak into
your life but I don't know many people a
two-year-old whose sex life isn't
screwed up and whose communication
schedule isn't screwed up and who's
their ability to talk to each other in
this group and so there's something
important about going back to the well
with your wife y'all too and saying all
right
we got a new marriage now it's one where
we love each other and we're committed
to each other and I still think you're a
smoke show and you think I'm pretty
looking
and we have this human in our house that
will be with us forever and we gotta
learn how to be married again and then
you can have another kid and you have to
do this whole thing over again and then
you have a third kid you're gonna get a
dog and you're gonna have to oh right
it's just gonna keep going
but don't try to get back to what your
marriage used to be because it's not
ever going to get back there you have a
new have a new marriage talk about what
that looks like create it you get to
create whatever you want
and in the meantime make peace with your
two-year-old son
make peace with him
he's not operating on as much sleep cool
We There are seasons and I gotta lay him
down he's gonna cry for a minute Babble
about until he finally goes to sleep
but the meta is I'm not gonna go to war
with him and when me and my wife have
when you and your wife I'll say that
when y'all have a challenge
let's go back to how do we create the
most peace in this home
what does that look like
and that might mean that we're going to
sleep in different beds for the next
couple of weeks
or we're gonna try we just I want pizza
every Friday I can't eat pizza because
when I eat pizza then and then I
breastfeed then he gets fussy I don't
know why he does he just does so I'm
gonna stop doing it we're gonna have to
make some sacrifices because our goal is
to have a non-anxious home
and we have a non-excious home then
people can rest and they can sleep and
then they can fill in the blank so go
seek that seek a non-anxious home
and stop going to war with a
two-year-old my brother you're a good
dad man you are a good dad
and the faster you can learn that you
are have value as a father not because
of what you're going to make your son do
but because you are always going to be
by your son's side the faster you learn
that the more peace your home will have